[MUSIC PLAYING]
shinytest2 is a
wonderful package
to help do regression testing
for your Shiny applications.
And we're going to
perform this regression
testing inside testthat.
And it's not regression testing
like linear model or something
like that.
This is a consistent
behavior over time,
and so we do not
want it to regress,
or we do not want it to change.
That's what I mean for
regression testing.
Before we get into
shinytest2 and how it works,
I just want to do this demo app.
This demo app is short,
a little toy example.
We have a fluid page
that has a text input.
It's like what's your name.
We can fill it out.
And then we also
have an action button
of greet, the text greet.
And then we have
two text outputs.
One is a greeting,
like "Hello, Barrett!"
And then the other
one is what is
the first letter in your name.
And it's neat, like
it's short little app.
So if I have it on
here, I have "Barrett."
I click Greet.
We get, "Hello Barrett!"
And if I'm here, we could
do like "Shinytest2."
"What is your name?
Shinytest2."
Greet, "Hello Shinytest2."
The first letter
is S. So it works.
It's a nice little app.
The app for the server--
what it does is we have a render
text that requires the name
and given a Greet click,
we will say, "Hello" name.
And then for the first letter
calculation, we require a name,
and we extract the first
character of the name.
And we send it tolower.
And we will bind all
of that calculations
to when the Greet
button is clicked.
Given this first letter,
whenever it updates,
we will then call
render text and say
the first letter in your
name is this first letter.
Awesome.
So let's imagine that I have--
well I have now created this
app, or I am working on a team,
and I want to make sure that
behaviors are consistent.
And tests are worth so much,
because you don't necessarily
need to communicate that
because the test is there.
And if the test breaks,
then we can figure out
what's happening.
And this also allows you to do
other things like sweeping code
changes.
Like what if I want to
change the GUTs of how
first letter is calculated.
I know this is a
small function, but it
could be much more complicated.
And having tests allow you
to do these sweeping changes
with confidence,
otherwise you just
look out and go, no,
that's close enough.
I don't know.
I hope I covered everything.
At least with tests, we can
say all of the tests pass.
And if you're
missing something, we
can add them in and then
make your test more robust.
When you run record
test, it opens up
your application in
the Chrome browser
or Chromium based browser.
Mine by default
is set to Chrome.
It'll have your
app in this IFrame.
And on the sidebar is
actually the recorder.
And we can see
there's some buttons
to call Expect Shiny values
or Expect screenshot.
And then there's also
an area of all the code
that will be executed
later that is
able to replay your recording.
So let's make a recording.
This is "What is your name?"
My name is Barrett.
So let's Greet Barrett.
And it'll say, "Hello Barret!
The first letter
in your name is b!"
And we can see that I set
inputs, name is Barrett.
And then I clicked
the Greet button,
and then an output
value is updated.
Awesome.
So I can test this or save
this as "hello-barrett,"
because that is the name that I
used and just for my reference.
And I'll click-- oh, but
I need to make sure first
before-- because I
can't save right away.
Well, let me.
So I need to say
Expect Shiny values.
And this will keep track--
the expect values will keep
track of all your input,
output, and exported values.
And exported values, we'll
get to in another video.
So once we have at
least one expectation,
we can then click
Save test and exit.
This will save the test and
then immediately run the test--
play back the test again.
And there are some
warnings, because we
have some new snapshots.
But that's OK.
And it looks like it all
passed, because there's also
nothing to say that the
snapshots would fail.
So let's take a look
at what was created.
So we have our
app that are here.
Awesome.
And then the tests folder,
it will be a sibling to that.
And in there, we will have a
testthat.R which internally,
it just has shinytest2 test app.
And then next to the testthat.R
is a testthat folder.
There there's three parts here.
The first part is
the snaps folder.
We'll go inside
that in a second.
The second one is the setup.R.
setup.R is there for you
when your little more
complicated apps where
you have an R folder or you
have global.R your Shiny
application.
We load all of those
information inside setup.R,
so that your tests have
that information available.
And the last one
is test-shinytest2.
This is the default file
name for recordings.
And it'll say
shinytest2 recording--
whatever name you gave.
So if we remember from the
recording that we made,
I created a new app.
It gives the same height and
width of the recording window.
That way when it replays,
it's under the same height
and width.
We then say app$set_inputs.
I typed in "Barrett"
for the name.
I then clicked the Greet
button, and then we called
app$expect_values.
Expect values is actually
a wrapper around shiny test
or actually a wrapper
around teststhat, expect,
snapshot file.
And this file will contain
a JSON representation
of your input, output,
and export values.
And that is stored
in the _snaps folder.
So we will open up _snaps.
We'll open up
shinytest2, because that
is the name of the
file, shinytest2.
So that name.
And then there was the first
JSON file that was created.
And this one if we click it, has
my input, output, and export.
So my inputs is at
the time of calling
expect values, which was
after setting an input
and after clicking Greet button.
We have input of "greet": 1 for
one time to click the button.
And name was Barrett.
The output was
"first_letter" was,
"The first letter
your name is b!"
And the greeting
is, "Hello Barrett!"
We didn't export
any test values yet.
But we'll get into
that in a later video.
So this is our test.
This is awesome.
We can, if we want, change
the height and width.
We can add more tests.
This is our test
file to work with.
And as a side note,
you might notice
that there's a PNG file here
created next to the JSON file.
This is there, because images
typically are fairly brittle.
And we don't like to use
them if we can help it,
because there's lots of
things outside of our control
that we can't account for, such
as if the R version updates,
or let's say you change
your version of DT,
or let's say you update
your system font.
Yeah.
There's many
different things that
are outside of Shiny, outside of
R that are not in your control.
And screenshots will
fail if this happens.
And no one likes to see
that, but that'll happen.
So if you can, try to do
everything as much as possible
using your JSON or your
values, and try to just test
the things that you own.
Unless you're a package
developer, then by all means,
we need to start taking
pictures and making sure things
render properly.
But otherwise, we can
give that responsibility
back to the app developers
not us as app developers.
But the image is there
to take us a snapshot
to let us know what
the app look like when
we called expect values.
So let's do, hello-barrett-001.
And this will open
up my application.
And we can see that
Chromote believes
the app looked like this where
it says, "What is your name?"
"Barret."
Greet.
"Hello Barret!"
Your first letter name is b.
Awesome.
That worked out great.
So one of the things that
we can do interactively
is we can take our app, and
we can run it in the console
as long as we're sitting in our
working directory of our Shiny
application.
This uses the app driver object.
And this object is something
that drives shinytest2.
And it runs your Shiny
application in the background.
And it also does your
communication with Chromote.
And so it handles all of that.
And we can set our inputs.
We can also retrieve inputs, and
outputs, or different values,
and click many different things.
So if we do this, one of the
things that I really enjoy is
that we can call app$view, and
view will open up a web page
of our headless Chrome browser.
And I think this is really,
really neat, because now it's
not a black box as
to what is happening.
So now I have my app.
And this is what Chromote
is representing as-- what
is happening within the app.
So if we actually just
step through this code
when in time, we can actually
see the app update to the left.
So we can call
set_inputs(name="Barret").
Click Greet.
And then if I wanted to, I
could call expect_values,
or I could even
say app$get_values.
And this will return
all the values.
Or if I wanted to do something
like just a particular one,
I could say app$get
values(output = "greeting").
And it's just that
one particular value.
Or since if it's just your one
value, you can say get value
and it'll turn back the regular
result. So it's very exciting.
You can debug your headless
tiny application, and headless
Chrome instance, and your
Shiny application all
at the same time.
Save the code that you want.
And then we can replay
them afterwards.
Or just going in the top
right and saying, run tests.
You will load up.
We'll get there and
eventually pass one
for that expect_values, because
that's the only expectation
in this whole test file.
Test complete.
Perfect.
[MUSIC PLAYING]